[Music]
and heroic passengers news Oh Rollie
Mitte Bob bullets / butterfly wings no I
want butterflies look avengers' thought
a crazed man from rushing into the
cockpit during their flight what the fun
it was this in the book in the air in
the ass Jiro's where did this happen
enter them all right so that sounds like
a terrorist attack or terrorist attempt
it can be seen that way I just I was
sitting right behind the cockpit and I
see some guy [ __ ] charging other
ocean forget for me or he had to take a
[ __ ] real bad in the cockpit oh maybe
we'll cause like you go up and then
there's the bathrooms before the first
class and I'm thinking usually
terrorists on a budget and they're not
trying to get first class and then you
got to pass the business class in the
first class before you get to the
cockpit all right so this a 25 year old
man his name is man notice
sorry on another pronounce that he is
from Sri Lanka
that's an island next to India one of my
favorite artists is from Sri Lanka
shut up tonight I didn't know she was
sure Lincoln he had just been released
from a psychiatric hospital in Melbourne
how wonderful yeah so and then so he
decided to buy a ticket the next logical
thing Kuala Lumpur in Malaysia
government-to-government leaves from
Australia from Melbourne yes so he got
on his flight and so they're reporting
that about 10 minutes into the trip from
Melbourne this man he starts to walk
from his feet to the economy seats
heading towards the cockpit and he's
holding something that witnesses are
saying was really big they've never seen
some
that's okay and so big salami hands up
going to the cosmic door and saying that
he's going to blow the plane up but he
has a bomb and so he's just making all
these Wow threats and saying I'm gonna
blow this plane up oh my god and that's
when three oddly heroes ran white boy
and they wrestled him down to the ground
and they completely immobilize them guys
go mmhmm yeah
so don't [ __ ] with the Australian mm-hmm
they fight kangaroos better get a the
all you football that's some [ __ ]
[ __ ] for the Crocodile Hunter came from
yeah they ain't afraid of [ __ ] they'd
gotten spiders yeah they like to fight
big oh is that a knife no also went [ __ ]
that's not a knife oh this is my boy
thanks for the safe he had my back on
that one yeah so apparently police
reporting that that was not an explosive
device that he was holding the trombone
so I've been seeing mostly with the
castle I just wanted to play a song for
the guys in the front have you seen this
print reports of some people are saying
it's like a Bluetooth speaker or
something like that or like a loser on a
bluff
yeah for sure there was not an explosive
Oh a psychiatric ward I forgot about
that
it's just so rude I take that back
that's so [ __ ] up doing that I don't
know I do remember I curl my hair I
brush my teeth no one is ever left from
elementary school you're trying to call
the person this way Gracie Oh anyway you
learn the meanest things in elements you
two kids are ruthless why it's just clay
why is this bad I don't know I just felt
like I was making fun of someone I just
felt bad I wanted to like all my family
members at my cartoons yeah so anyway so
the flight was had to turn back around
you [ __ ] he went back to Melbourne
and then they were saying that
others were kept on board for 90 minutes
like once they landed AC was on you know
so they were looking for potential bombs
and like throughout the whole airport
and like in the actual aircraft luckily
they didn't find anything I would
immediately strip the butt ass naked
yeah
to make sure that there's no buttons
bombs or anything where he could set
anything off with my finger and ask -
yep you better get the file you might be
hiding [ __ ] what the glove right I don't
know in the heat of the moment I wrestle
his ass down beat the [ __ ] out and take
his clothes off hog-tie is asked to take
my hands [ __ ] then stick my hands
down his [ __ ] mouth make them throw
up to make sure I was also not hiding a
[ __ ] bomb it yeah cuz he have a
button and he kicks it out you could
press the bug up so imma [ __ ] stick
my head up his ass during hard times but
not its flavored and then I stick in
China's [ __ ] mouth showed him all
four fingers - that's a lot of fingers
yeah now you stretch that [ __ ]
yeah this is example oh you may have a
curry yeah so this 25 year old man
attempted to blow up the plane
apparently he was studying to be a chef
in Australia
what the [ __ ] there he was there on a
student visa from where Sri Lanka no
sorry yes yes interesting there yeah and
so um the police determined that he
doesn't have any terrorist ties that he
was just not he's just cuckoo for cocoa
puffs so this is the man why does he
look like a Sri Lankan snoop dog really
does he look like a new Bob Marley mix
he actually it looks pretty handsome
yeah so this is when they tied him in
the aircraft to cut is that what about
flight attendants yeah
closing with him it's a science really
keeping data and then this is over the
video a video holy went on board oh I
know
the actual tackle sorry guys I was
trying to find that - yes I wanted this
here you go
what airline was that Melvin oh yeah
it's a real pot I can see everyone in
the face everyone in the same there's a
guy recording everything Hugh with a
camera they have their own camera man
that's hard
thanks Ramon LAPD y'all need to do that
to look like Australian SWAT yeah so
luckily everyone says nothing crazy
happened it was just this guy claiming
to wanna do some [ __ ] but he couldn't so
that's good
yeah I always fear stuff like that
happening when I'm on a plane I try not
to think about it
I just tried actually I do get scared so
many times and I fell like crazy
turbulence or like I just think crazy
scenarios but then I just tell myself
like to calm down and I'm just like well
it's my time ago it's my time ago and
that usually kind of like yeah actually
how I feel that sometimes - for I don't
usually get scared he'll fight but very
few times that I though Scott's just pop
into my head I'd do something like well
it's my time
turbulence is scary hell yeah I remember
when we were going I think it was us
going off trail you know Malaysia
remember how it was a crazy turbulent
and I was sitting next to up to two
other artists and they were freaking I
think I was her first international
flight and I'm already like kind of used
to flying internationally so they're
like the turbines is crazy they're
freaking out and then they look at me
they're like is this normal and I'm like
yeah this is nothing - this is chilled
inside I was like holy [ __ ] I'm so
[ __ ] scared you're so cool you're so
nice you don't want to take them Jasmine
once we lovely to those not normal I was
[ __ ] scare and they're like oh my god
thank you for not [ __ ] scaring us
every time there's like turbulence I
watch you know the ritchie valens movie
guys on the plane that's the first thing
about my [ __ ] I'm gonna be known as that
comedian if I can die in an airplane god
damn it Wow you think you're crazy
business
but it's okay lyrics here watch the
ground UMass is famous like crazy
oh think I'm famous but I do have a
fanbase fine I didn't even mention that
this was on a Malaysian Airlines flight
they still do flies like you have heard
the phrase we're missing I thought they
would like that's the economy of it all
right probably $20 slices [ __ ] yeah so
those of you guys I don't know which I'm
sure you do back in 2014 there was a
flight that had 238 people on board that
went missing literally like the Bermuda
Triangle or something right disappeared
again you gotta figure that I ain't and
in four months later another Malaysian
Airlines flight was shot down over
Ukraine that had 283 passengers and 15
crew members I never fly Malaysia
Airlines thought that didn't reply and
my agent like once it was happening and
more people were making jokes like do
disappear imagine I am also Chinese so
if it was the cheapest flight I might
fly it high not during those times I
liked it though my two favorite
international ones was a Malaysian
single Singapore's night was really nice
I flew Malaysia Thai Airways at
Singapore they're like the three
Singapore to Japan yeah in a porta [ __ ]
no bomb I like a heavy curry skewer
sticks it's so good so so so good you
guys were on this place do you think
you'd be one of those three heroes me
right now no depends on how tired I am
I'm moving to the front and he says that
he's gonna blow the plane up Jim
probably only if you're in the front
well I don't we're in the back all right
you have to sprint really far just [ __ ]
your fart is there like you know I mean
you got like the grandmother stretching
in [ __ ]
great yeah but if I'm in the front and
then he said he's gonna blow the plane
up then I'm like well I'm gonna die
anyway so I might as well beat his ass
hmm got you Michael I think I grew bored
I mean it's like if I was right there
when he ran by and I heard those words I
try to do something but like once your
and by me I'm like well I don't know I'm
is kind of a lot of us you can't hijack
the brain yeah okay it's making threat I
would comply that's what I would try to
do right uh uh I got a bomb oh this is
what we're going to do I don't know
what's her agenda we're trying to do I'm
gonna fly over here or you can try to
kill us no I just want to hijack to play
them oh they'll always comply but if
he's like [ __ ] Plato I'm like why do
you want to do that cuz I'm just kinda
at all about something well [ __ ] I'm
gonna die anyways then I'm not gonna
come from Ibiza you're give me yeah you
know toys I've died anyways might as
well go down like that
hey you think terrorists are that
honorable they're gonna tell you like
I'm not going to kill you what do you
believe them cuz they're saying like if
they're if they're saying that they're
not going to kill you then I'm going to
do it you know some resolved agenda like
doctors medical monitor then I'll be
like oh [ __ ] okay the supporters plan
guys trying to draw for life but in my
in the meantime I'm still gonna try to
find a way to disarm them yeah you can't
just go immediately because like you
know what if he just pushes the button
because you stood up and you ran toward
them it's going to be all your fault but
if you had made up his mind he's gonna
blow that plate up no matter what you
might as well just try now yep I think
for me ideally I would like to help but
then another part of me is like I'll be
afraid I would call a [ __ ] it up
like let's say if I try to charge at him
I end up getting like caught in like one
of the dishes well yeah you know this is
like I feel like incidents like that
would happen and you forgot to undo the
seatbelt I'm they already know and [ __ ]
the antennas are there but they would
ideal to execute them out like I don't
know that's very questionable is
probably what if the terrorist was like
super obedient to like he's standing up
and then you get up as soon as he pops
ankles back there's oh [ __ ] that's
defective gotta waste as a put so the
turbulence goes away blood went back up
what the turbulence goes away decision
oh yes if a gallon of food and beverages
are coming up with their vision he's not
trying to charge the cross maybe they
all [ __ ] the crutch coming I did order
the [ __ ] vegan meals well [ __ ] I
think first and foremost I would watch
where his hands are because if he says I
got a bomb and all that stuff and it's
like well what
the button was how's it going to
detonate because you have to push
something yeah or if it's time that
we're all [ __ ] anyway so mmm so scared
to just think about it is scary I don't
know what to do I'll say one thing but
like if I'm far I'm just gonna relax
yeah but it really happens who knows
what's gonna happen
Oh times like that I wish I was a girl
cuz I just [ __ ] take off my shirt and
then start licking my own titties and it
like run up to him real slow and then at
that last minute stop talking it's
[ __ ] either what did we just shoot
you like this is like I have any sex no
no you don't know the power of the 10
yeah you don't know guys
he's just gonna start drooling put the
bomb down start [ __ ] play with his
wee-wee yep hey guys thanks for watching
that last episode did you love it I know
you did so make sure to give this video
a big thumbs up and to watch more videos
you can watch em up here
you
[Music]